or something
but there's a problem
okay great all right so uh welcome back
everyone so uh so as I mentioned in the
first part
um we are going to spend a little bit
more time on a smooth gradient design
and talk about this uh uh this idea of
acceleration right so as we mentioned in
the previous uh talk uh for gradient uh
the gradient descent algorithm for
smooth functions and also well
conditioned functions doesn't achieve
the optimal convergence guarantee for
those classer problems uh there's a
different class of algorithms which is
related but also quite different which
is called accelerator methods that will
give us the optimal convergence rate and
um and as some of you might know there
this is actually is one of the most
fundamental results in uh in convex
optimization that we can achieve this
accelerated uh convergences and and the
algorithms
and that have been designed in that
setting are quite beautiful and quite
impactful both interior and practice so
they're pretty fundamental to the design
of fast albums in both of those settings
uh and at the same time uh they're also
quite mysterious or they're perceived to
be mysterious and there's been quite a
few developments uh um that led to
different interpretations of the
original axillary ingredients and Method
and related methods and uh and uh that
means that my job is quite difficult
because I have to make a choice into
yeah in this large space of
possibilities so I chose a specific uh
algorithm actually two algorithms that I
want to show you and I just want to
motivate how one might go about
designing those algorithms from from
what we've seen so far and uh let me
sort of uh preface that with the caveat
that this is a mind version and yours
could vary and I'm very happy to talk to
uh to anyone uh that might have a
different perspective I think it's it's
quite valuable
uh so so we're going to see two
algorithms uh that achieve the
accelerator rates uh they're related uh
but at the same time uh different as
we'll talk about later and if time
permits uh we're also uh talk a little
bit more about four pointers uh many
things uh that I could not uh tell you
about in these two lectures as well as
maybe we'll have time for some analysis
so maybe we'll see the analysis of
smooth gradient design hopefully okay
so so with uh further Ado so let us dive
in and try to derive accelerated methods
um but before we do that
um
the clicker works so before we do that
um let us briefly recap some of the main
ideas that we saw in gradient descent
and uh what we saw in gradient descent
so so once again this is a smooth
objective function so so we saw that we
can use smoothness to get an upper bound
a global upper bound on the function
which comes from smallness so we have
the simple quadratic function that is
operating in the function everywhere
and because the function is also convex
we saw that that means that we have this
Global lower bounds which
uh which are uh given by the first order
Taylor approximation and at the gradient
descent algorithm relied very strongly
on both of those two
um properties in order to achieve a good
convergence right so so much gave us
this nice problem that we could uh use
as a proxy for the function and
convexity gave us a nice a fine lower
bound uh that we can use to gauge uh how
far away the the minimum function value
can be so so how small can the minimum
function of value can be
right so uh since in order to do better
the ingredient descent an important idea
that has emerged in the study of
accelerator methods is that we can
actually construct a better lower bounds
to the objective function uh that are
um more informative than the basic lower
bound that we get from convexity
and and in this lecture I want to give
you uh some some recipe for building
such lower bounds and and give some
intuition how how to use it to achieve
acceleration and actually derive an
algorithm along the way
all right so so this is the goal of the
lecture let's build better lower bound
uh to our function uh and and hope that
we can leverage it to converge faster
all right
okay
so so before we uh we do that so so let
me also uh make another algorithm design
choice that will take us a little bit
further away from uh gradient descent
which is that uh let us allow ourselves
a little bit more flexibility in the
algorithm design
uh by separating
our goal of constructing a solution
which is an approximate solution from
our goal of learning about the function
by constructing suitable lower bounds to
the function
so ingredient descent if you think about
it we did both of those things using our
just one solution which was X right so
we have this Idris XD they were our main
solution and there were also the points
where we created the gradient and
therefore we got uh this linear a fine
lower bounds uh from those gradients
um but they need not be the same uh so
we we can query the gradient at other
points that are not our main solution
and this gives us a little bit more
flexibility in the algorithm design so
so let us do that so so let us use that
just to be consistent with gradient
descent let us use the itres XT
uh to query the gradients so those will
be the points at which we're going to
query the gradients and those will be
the points at which we're going to get
lower balance from convexity right so
these a fine lower balance just as
before
but let us allow us to use a different
sequence of Interest let us call it ziti
to construct our main solution
so so with that in mind let us go back
to this task that that we set out for
ourselves which is to get lower a better
lower bounds uh on the function
and in fact here the the observation is
quite simple which is that ingredient
descent
um we're only using the current lower
amount that is given by the current it
red but in fact we've observed quite a
few gradients along the way right so in
iteration T we've already observed T
gradients Each of which is going to give
us a an offline lower amount to the
function
and as is hopefully clear from this
picture two or even two of those lower
bounds is actually better than just a
single one right so
um so so so we could potentially uh try
to be less forgetful and not forget
about all of this useful information
that we got from the past gradients that
is giving us a better lower bound on the
function right so so it's another voice
right so if you look at each of these
gradients that we've created so far each
of them is giving us a lower bound right
so here we have a lower bound from X1
but also lower bound from X2
and those two lower bars together they
give us more information than each of
them alone
so for example if we could look at the
maximum of those right so it's much
better than each of them alone
so so we could use the maximum as as a
global lower bound so that that is fine
is it is a lower bound but it has one
downside uh which turns out to be quite
significant which is that at this lower
bound is going to get very complicated
right so the more gradients we're going
to get the the most more piecewise
linear this function is going to get so
so it gets very complicated very quickly
it is very hard to work with such a
lower bound although we're in principle
we could
it turns out that we can do something uh
fairly simpler which is simply to maybe
let's say average these lower bounds or
more generally just take some context
combination of these lower bounds so so
for example here this dashed line is the
average of those two lower bounds uh so
so we're going to work with that right
so so the the convex combination of
these lower bounds maintains this nice
structure of having an offline function
which is uh very easy to work with
so so let us go with the simpler choices
that it's not as powerful but it's much
less complicated
right so so we settled that uh we're
combining these lower bounds uh using
some convex combination
and and this is actually completely up
to us how we do this uh this choice and
actually our priori is not at all uh
clear how we should combine them
and um so so let us allow ourselves just
to uh just have the flexibility to
choose any ways to combine these lower
bounds
and and here uh we're going to choose
this place to be at least one right so
so we have this weight 80 one for each
uh lower bound energy thread and we're
using them to combine uh all of the
lower balance that we got from
complexity into a single affine lower
bound which is the converse combination
of those what
okay so so one thing uh that is good for
intuition uh which uh which uh might be
good to keep in mind is that we we will
use the weights that are actually
increasing with t
and and this is uh and and this is uh
putting more emphasis on later iterates
which are hopefully better Solutions so
the intuition is that uh as we're
getting closer to the as we're growing
uh as we're further along in the
optimization process so in later
iterations we should be getting closer
to the optimum
and therefore the later iterates are
better Solutions and we should emphasize
the information that we get from them
more and this is uh and this is captured
by us using uh weights that are
increasingly
you can think generally for now that we
have these weights that we're using to
combine the lower grounds
okay
good so so we've got our lower bound
right it is this Converse combination
some suitable convex combination of all
of the lower bounds we have so far
and we would like to use it somehow
right so so now that we have the lower
bound we need to think about how how
were we hoping to use that and how did
it come about uh coming to play into
Brady and the Sun
so uh so if we think back uh at gradient
descent there was this optimization
perspective that I offered at that time
uh that uh that I that I suggest that
it's a good way to think about gradient
descent even if it's unconstrained and
we we already saw why that was
beneficial in just in gradient descent
but let us exploit it even further now
in auxiliary the gradient the Sun so
what was that optimization perspective
so what he said is that if we can think
of the next iterative gradient descent
as uh being the optimizer of of this uh
objective which is combining the lower
bound that we get from convexity
with uh with a term which is that the
movement that uh how much uh the point
is moving from the current point
the current solution XD
right so so that's uh that's the
optimization perspective that we saw for
gradient descent where we minimizing
this combination of the lower bound and
the movement together
so if we take that perspective now given
that we have a better lower bound
hopefully better lower bound and we're
more Global uh lower bound on the
function that is taking into account all
of the what we've seen so far
uh let us try to use that in a similar
way so let us take inspiration from
Grady understand
and essentially Plug and Play right so
before we're using a simple lower bound
just at the current it round now now we
have a more sophisticated one that is
taking all of the previously threads so
let us use it just like that
so so we'll so here what we're doing is
that in order to construct our main
solution
which now is no longer X right so if you
remember uh we allowed ourselves to use
a different solution than the uh than
the sequence where we compute the
gradients that was ZTE so it's our our
solution ZT let us compute it by
considering this more sophisticated
lower bound that we constructed
and minimize the lower bound plus uh
some movement term right just just like
just like Brady understand so Plug and
Play
but now uh we need to think about uh
what should go in the movement part
right so so in gradient descent right uh
we we had uh the moon was simply the
distance between uh the new uh point and
and XT which was the current idiot uh
because we were looking locally at the
linear approximation at the current
point
and uh we didn't really use any Global
structure we also used just a fine lower
bound at that particular point but here
we are taking a more global view where
we're incorporating all of the previous
lower bounds and all of the previous
iterates
and it turns out because of that uh it
makes sense to actually use a different
movement
term which is simply to look at the
distance not from the previous it read
which was ZT minus one but rather the
very first one
so we would just reference back to the
initial Point uh zero and uh and our
movement is simply the distance to the
initial point
okay so so this is my it might seem a
little bit strange but as as we'll see a
little bit more in a bit
um yeah that this actually makes quite a
bit of sense given the kind of lower
bound that we're actually considering
here
what's up
so so that gives us
um one of the strategy that we could use
to update our main sequence right so so
it was just more or less Plug and Play
Taking inspiration from gradient descent
where we plugged in our
hopefully much better lower bound and we
also add the movement uh to make sure
we're not moving too far away and we're
combining those two and minimizing the
combined objective
tends to change Zero to the average
point of that's not correcting
so so like a reset as you go along
that is simply the one hour piece almost
yes
that's a great question so changa is
asking
um do other choices for the reference
point right so here we're looking at the
movement with respect to some reference
points so greatly understand the
reference point was just the previous
season
here we're using the initial Point as
the reference point and we're Computing
how much we move from that point
and John is asking are there other
natural strategies like for example
looking at the average of the internet
that will also work here
um
so
I
I'm the short answer is I'm not sure uh
for this particular type of lower bounds
uh this is a very Natural Choice and
we'll see the intuition for that
um but for others if we change the lower
bound slightly we may be able to use
other reference points but I'm off the
top of my head I will have to think
about it so maybe I can maybe phases in
which you get a new
starting point based on the previous
phase or something like that I mean
yes uh so so what Phil is suggesting is
that maybe you can also do it in phases
where
um we break things up and and we allow
the initial point to change so so each
each phase will start with its own
initial solution which let's say is
perhaps the
I'm guessing the last eat red from from
the beauty displays uh can we uh can we
do it that way as well so so I think
it's sort of
um maybe the short answer is uh I would
expect all of this can be done uh and
one will computationally get an
algorithm like this uh but uh I will
definitely have to think about the
specific details
it's interesting you're playing with two
different ideas right separating the
excess with disease
uh as far as
so that's that's a very good question so
uh well so the the there was an
observation and a question so the
observation was that
um uh there are two ideas that play here
one is that uh we are decoupling the the
construction of the uh of the lower
balance uh from the construction of the
main solution and also the we're using
uh better uh lower balance right so
those are the two ideas that we're using
here so that's correct and the question
was uh would either just only one of
those ideas alone uh suffice
[Music]
um
so
if if we're simply coupling the so
um so uh I suppose so yes uh but I think
it uh we need to think about it uh very
carefully right so so if we're just
simply separating x and z we still need
uh a good way to update X and update
these so so that by itself it doesn't
allow us to to go beyond uh just
separating x and z so so we would have
to use some ideas and this uh these
ideas that we're using here
um allow us to to separate x and z and
also uh
um come up with appropriate strategies
for updating x and z
um
for the the second one uh is which is is
it necessary to separate them
um so saying our in this Viewpoint yes
uh because our goal is actually to
explore the function more
uh in that sense of course there could
be other ways to do it but here we want
to explore the function more so so we
want to be able to query gradients that
are not necessarily our Solutions uh
simply for the purpose of getting more
information on the function from the
lower bound perspective so I may be
exploring over here so my Solutions are
here or maybe even here and they're
pretty good
I have no reason to jump all the way
here
but I may want to do that
to learn more what's on the other side
I hope that makes sense
what's this
question
great questions
all right good so
um so so that gives us a strategy for
updating Z and also it just start with
as we did for gradient Descent of course
we can drop uh the terms so so here we
have like a complicated optimization
problem uh but several of those terms
are constant that do not actually depend
on the variable we're minimizing over so
we can drop those and simplify the
update a bit right so so we can just uh
drop all of those constant terms okay
all right so so that gives us an update
for the main entrance right so we're
updating in this way which was motivated
by our our choice of lower bounds and
also the way the gradient descent
algorithm works at least from the
optimization perspective that we saw
uh so so let us follow the gradient
descent a bit more in this regard and
also
um set these uh step sizes beta T right
that we had there right so so one over
itathi was this coefficient that we used
to weigh the movement term uh with
respect to the lower bound term so
that's what we did in gradient descent
and and the way we said it for smooth
functions uh that leverage this one is
was to say set it at e to one over the
smoothness
so so let us go ahead and follow
gradient descent once more in that
particular case as well and set it
actually to be one around
and and that it specifies the step size
and uh and we have a complete update for
Z provided that that we have the
gradients so we haven't talked about
just yet how to determine where we're
going to query the gradient but uh at
alista we know how to update Z once we
have those gradients okay
so so with that in mind let us mention
an important caveat which is uh you we
can think of it as both a caveat but
also a very important feature of this
approach uh which is that unlike uh this
put gradient descent algorithm that we
saw right so so we saw the smooth
gradient the sun we chose the step sizes
to be one overall precisely so so that
we can make a step size that is as large
as we could make it while still making
sure that uh the objective was
monotonically non-increasing
so so one might ask whether a similar uh
property still holds in in the setting
in this update that we have here where
we're actually using a different lower
bound and the answer is no so so now the
objective function is no longer
monotonically decreasing or
non-increasing uh it could sometimes go
up and sometimes it goes down
and uh and this is in some sense a price
that we're paying for uh learning more
about the function in from the lower
bound side so so we're willing to
sacrifice this monotonic CD process in
this steady progress in the homes that
we're actually learning more about the
function that will ultimately allow us
to converge faster
sorry so one over 80 was completely
outside
yeah oh sorry the question was whether
uh we're missing one over capital A D
from the update and uh and uh
um yeah so so in the simplified uh
update uh we dropped all of the constant
Trends including this one over Capital
IP factor that we had right at the front
which was multiplying everything in this
particular choice of uh
like outside the E30 thing like this
this is being linear combination of
lower bounds right but the one by two
heater thing is separate right so
yes it's a side I put it inside
the regularization is sort of getting
weaker yes
thank you that's a that's a great job
all right
it is increasing over time
so so so this is uh just uh just to
maybe sort of make a small comment
before we go on so as it was already
pointed out these are specific choices
that we're making here and there are
many other ideas that one could try to
play with and that's actually I think a
great idea to uh to to get uh some
understanding of the accelerator methods
to consider all of the different ways we
could try to go about deriving an update
scheme so for the students in the
audience who are interested in this I
think this is a wonderful exercise
all right great good so since I
mentioned there's this caveat that the
function value is no longer
monotonically decreasing uh and that's
both uh the caveat but it's also by
Design and this actually turns out to be
very important for acceleration
um but this brings about the question
whether uh we should still use the last
iterate as our final solution uh and uh
and because the function value is not no
longer volatility decreasing it actually
makes sense to use the non-smooth
gradient descent idea of averaging the
threads and that's what we uh we we can
use here as well so so we can uh have
our actual solution that we're going to
return and to be the average of this uh
ZTE threads but uh now because we have
this much more sophisticated lower bound
that is emphasizing different iterates
differently it makes sense to have a
weighted average of the interest that
incorporates those weights so so we we
take a weighted average of the zis with
the ways given by IAI as well
and just as before uh we're using
weights that are changing with E and in
fact they're increasing with t to put
more emphasis on later iterations
but all right so so that tells us how we
update Z and it also tells us how we're
going to construct the final solution so
the the only thing that remains for us
to understand is where should we query
our gradients
sorry one more question about that is um
f of z bar T well that's not a big
decrease
uh yes
so so we are going to return the capital
is the so the bar
C where it is the last
three so the average of all of them
so
um that is our final solution
so so at which point should we create
right so so that's uh that's uh that's a
very important question right because uh
the the points at which we created the
painting give us the lower bounds that
we are going to use
so uh so uh so if we think about it and
actually if we sort of uh work through a
little bit of the analysis of gradient
descent and as some of us have done in
the past uh you realize that there's
this very uh very interesting thing that
happens so so sometimes uh uh we we can
make a very simple mistake in the
analysis of gradient descent that gives
us a
um a guarantee that is too good to be
true
and and that happens when uh we we
accidentally use the gradient at uh this
uh the current solution the new iterate
that we actually don't have
so so if you if you want to try it you
can you can see that that is actually a
very very good way to to get a very fast
conversion that unfortunately is not
correct
and sort of uh so what happens there is
that actually if we could somehow query
the gradient at the current solution
that would actually be great but of
course we cannot do that right so so I
cannot query it at iteration T right uh
I need uh the first p gradients in order
to compute ZT
so so we don't actually have ZT we only
have the first T minus one
so so we cannot query at z bar T
um so so that is uh of course a very
fundamental difficulty there
uh but
uh there's here's a nice idea how about
we just proceed optimistically right so
in gradient descent are intuitively we
should not be moving too much from the
the current nature right it is still an
iterative somewhat local method right
should not be too different from zp
minus one right the the previous it read
so so how about we proceed
optimistically and we assume that this
is actually the case that they're
actually pretty close so and we so so in
other words let us use ZT minus one in
lieu of ZT
right so so before right we had the
Commerce combination of the uh the first
theater uh iterates and and now we only
have the first T minus one of them so so
let's just add ZT minus one in uh where
ZT was
so so that's so that's that's a one
approach we can take high for XD
so see if we put all of those things
together we're going to get an actual
algorithm right so so now we've
specified almost everything except that
the choices of weights
so so let us put everything together
right so so we've arrived in an
algorithm that looks uh something like
this so we start with some initial Point
uh Z zero and we pick some weights right
80.
and we perform this update for T
iterations right
so we we uh query the gradient at this
point x t which is using some
combination of the uterus from from the
previous iterations in an optimistic way
thinking ahead of the the actual
solution which is a weighted average of
disease
and we update z uh using this combined
lower bound that we had plus this
movement uh with respect to the initial
point
and at the end we uh we uh returned the
weighted average of all of the
so that is the algorithm uh so this
algorithm was uh discovered in a couple
of papers and it goes by a couple of
different names
um and uh it's one of them is HD Plus in
connection to AGD which is the
accelerator gradient descent method of
Nazareth
so so that's the algorithm so modular
the weights are this is a complete
algorithm so so let me uh
what the law stands for uh the the usual
so the question is what does the plus
stand for
um
so
what's the difference
so uh so yes this is the question is
what is the difference between this
method and uh the original uh one of the
original Industrials actually the great
incentives uh so maybe we can take that
question offline it takes a bit of time
to explain but I'm happy to
very interested
so if you define exp
minus one that's not good enough
I don't
know how to finalize them I think
I would have to think about that
um so yes oh sorry I keep forgetting to
repeat the question so the question was
um
so so here we said all right that um
we're going to drop in zd-1 for zde
and try to mimic the way the actual
weighted average is constructed so what
if we didn't do that
and just take z bar T minus one
um
so
I so
I think that there's a
fairly
there's a fairly good technical reason
why uh that might not be a good idea but
maybe that is a discussion we can take
offline since I I don't have a
concise explanation as to what is
happening
um
all right good
um good so so that uh so that is an
algorithm but how about these weights
right so so how do should we choose
these words uh so we said that they
should be increasing with t uh to put
more emphasis on the later iterations
but what is a good choice for it uh so
it turns out that a good choice for it
is to just decide them to basically T so
so it's t times so actually one plus T
over three is for example one choice
that will work
so so there then on the other uh
literacy uh that which means that uh
right as the iteration counter is
increasing the the weight is increasing
as roughly t
and and this this will give us adaptable
convergence that we mentioned before so
so the convergence uh to get an Epsilon
approximate solution now improves from
one over Epsilon which was the smooth
gradient the same guarantee to square
root of one over Epsilon which is
significantly better
and this is the optimal um
convergence guarantee in this Black Box
model
um so so this is uh this is one
algorithm
so so one uh one thing we cannot do uh
just to get a little bit more intuition
is actually to think about what happens
back in the unconstrained setting right
so here uh so this algorithm works even
in the constraint setting right so we're
optimizing over the feasible domain uh
but let us uh see what happens if the
domain was actually unconstrained so the
key was all all of R to the D
so so then write this optimization
problem it's very easy to solve right so
so just take the the gradient and set it
to zero and see what happens right
so if we do that
we're going to see that ziti is the
initial point zero minus one overall
times the sum of this linear
combinations of the gradients right with
weights AI
and uh and so so that's the completely
unrolling uh zp all the way to zero
uh but we of course we could look at it
a little bit more locally and observe
that uh this is also the previous itra
zt-1 minus uh the uh the current
gradient right one over L times 80 times
the current gradient
so uh so so we can also think of it a
little bit more locally as the T minus 1
minus uh some some Factor times the hot
the current gradient
and if we want to turn it back into an
optimization problem just like we did
for gradient descent uh this is uh this
gives us this update here right right
where we have 80 times the inner product
between the current gradient and Y which
is what we're minimizing over plus L
over 2 which is like in radian descent
times the the distance squared from the
previous e-trad
so so here right uh in in this rewriting
of the update at least in the
unconstrained setting uh we we go back
to actually measuring the movement with
respect to the previous iterate as
opposed to the initial one
and uh this is also provide some
intuition as to why the initial
um uh the initial iterate was a good
choice for the movement in in this and
in this form of the update we actually
where we actually use all of the
previous gradients
okay so so in the on constraint setting
this is an alternative way uh to write
the update which is at least a
semantically closer to gradient descent
right so we have uh the inner product
with the current gradient uh plus the
the movement with respect to the
previous idroid
and The crucial point is that now we're
actually weighing uh the inner product
by a suitable way that is actually
increasing with t
and uh this is the unconstrued version
of a different algorithm uh which was
proposed by line is called acsa
um and it was a proposed for for a
different motivation uh in the
stochastic setting and we're going to
talk a little bit about this in a bit
um and acsa in the in the constraint
setting is simply uh this update right
where we actually use uh a constrained
domain
so uh so it's in the unconstrained
setting the two algorithms are exactly
the same but in the constraint setting
they're actually different so one is
using this
um can think of it unrolled
uh it was also called like a dual
averaging style of update whereas uh the
other is using more of a gradient the
sense to how approach
okay
and as I mentioned uh these two
algorithms are two of several
accelerator methods that have been
developed along the way and uh they're
they're also different from accelerated
gradient descent so necessarov's
original method and I'm happy to talk
about the differences offline
and one motivation for for driving these
alternate methods was uh uh
the fact that sometimes
um acceleration doesn't play very well
with stochastic gradients
so
so in the deterministic setting where we
have exact gradients all of these
different accelerator methods uh
theoretically they give us they all give
us the optimal convergence they converge
at the optimal rate uh and uh behave
very nice theoretically but if we go to
other settings such as stochastic
gradients we actually start to observe
some differences between these different
methods
and this appears both interior and in
practice some methods might not converge
at all uh even in theory or in practice
or they might converge at a different
rate
and if you're interested in in this
topic
um what is hard had a a very interesting
blog post uh from a few years ago where
he actually uh looked into this for
specifically for National's accelerator
grade in the sun method
and you can have a look
all right
so uh so so let me uh make a summary and
also give you some four pointers of
everything we've seen so far and if time
permits we can talk a little bit about
analysis of gradient descent uh just to
summarize so what are we seeing today
was a gradient template uh and and also
uh for for both in the unaccillary
setting and the accelerated setting and
and combined it gives us a powerful
framework for Designing fast albums for
fundamental problems both in the
discrete optimizations such as maximum
flows and and many other problems as
well as a continuous optimization
problems in many domains
and uh and this is a very fascinating
and very broad uh area uh and there are
many topics we did not get to cover
which are very uh very helpful uh and
I'll briefly mention some of these here
in case uh people are interested in
learning more about them
so so one thing we uh uh we did
throughout was that we stayed in this
simple setting where we were measuring
distances using euclidean distances so
everything was I mean uh we were
measuring distances in the euclidean
norm and we're designing the algorithms
accordingly
but it turns out that the euclidean norm
is not necessarily the best way to
measure uh how two points uh uh how
similar are two points in certain
settings so for example if you think
about probability distribution so if the
domain is the probability Simplex
um uh it turns out that there are better
ways to measure the distances between
two probability distributions and some
of you who have seen information Theory
it might have come across Notions such
as the KL Divergence that is very good
for for that setting and um and uh
there's this very Broad and Powerful
framework called Mirror descent that
allows us to incorporate distances that
are not necessarily euclidean and and
derive very good algorithms with a very
good performance
um there's also Frameworks for Designing
offline algorithms like the eater
developments like the ones we've seen in
the stock that are actually derived from
online optimization uh so so many of us
are familiar with the multiplicate ways
update method uh which comes from the
learning from expert advice setting and
there's oh they're also other ideas such
as The Following the Leader algorithms
and also things like optimistic gradient
descent and many other ideas that were
designed in the online optimization
setting which have very useful uh
applications in even for offline
optimization
and another topic we didn't talk about
was
how should we do constraint optimization
where efficient projections are not
available uh and uh in certain
combinator optimization problems uh
quadratic optimization and projections
are very expensive but other
optimizations such as linear
optimization is more efficient so so one
can think about exam for example
um the greedy algorithm for metroids and
uh and as a modular polytops there we we
can do linear optimization modes faster
and there's a question of whether we can
leverage that instead of projections and
and there are methods that are designed
to do that such as the front volt
algorithms and many others
okay
so that's another uh topic that we
haven't talked about yet I hope to give
you one analysis but uh uh for and just
for uh unaccelerated uh smooth gradient
the Sun
um but it is a very fascinating and very
revealing topic is to understand how to
analyze the convergence of all of these
gradient descent methods and to that
there are many wonderful preferences and
I quite like uh this survey by nikhil
and anupam which has was very revealing
to me when I started studying this topic
but all right so so with that in mind I
think we have a few minutes left
is that right we have a few minutes left
uh so so let me at least try to give you
a glimpse of how one might design an
analysis of gradient descent methods and
I'll pick something that is a relatively
simple also so that we can go over it in
a few moments
so
so let us go back at smooth gradient the
Sun so without acceleration so we we saw
this algorithm in the first part uh of
the in this lecture uh so she was this
is a very nice algorithm that I use the
quadratic upper Bond coming from
smoothness and minimize that and that
gave us a great understand uh which Step
size is one around
so so let us show that it converges as
this one over T rate uh that that I
mentioned in the first part or in other
words that this one over Epsilon a rate
where Epsilon is the approximation that
we're shooting for okay
and along the way I hope to sort of uh
give you a glimpse of how one might go
about reasoning about these iterative
methods and some of the ideas that go
behind the analysis and hopefully you
can use that to uh to analyze some of
them some of the other settings that
we've considered okay so so we're done
uh let us uh go ahead and do that so so
the first idea uh that we're going to
use uh for the analysis is to actually
leverage movements so if you remember
smallness was this property that the
creation doesn't change very fast so if
we don't move too much the gradient
doesn't change by too much
so so that means that intuitively the
next iterate which is XD plus one I
should be uh intuitively close to the
current iterate XD right by by the way
we designed the optimization method
right so we incorporate the movement
from XT as part of our objective to
enforce the algorithm to encourage the
algorithm to stay close to XP
so so we can use this idea to try to
analyze the function value Gap right so
we have this new solution XD plus one
and we're trying to understand how far
away is from the optimum
and the way we can do that is this first
Edge is just break it up and see how
much we're improving uh right that's how
much better is f of x t plus one
compared to f of x d right so so that is
the first part uh plus uh the function
value gap of x t f of x t minus f of x
star
and uh using our information that XD
plus 1 and x t should be fairly close to
each other uh it seems reasonable to use
munas uh to Upper bound uh this uh this
difference
and for for this part right so the
function value Gap to X star so there uh
we need to leverage a convexity right
because the only way we know how to
gauge how uh how large f of x star is is
via our a fine lower bounds given by the
gradient so we can use that to to Upper
bound to that room as well
okay so so let's go ahead and do that so
we apply smoothness for the first
difference and we apply convexity for
the second difference
and uh this is what we got right so uh
so so this uh from smallness we get this
inner product plus this distance squared
term so this is the movement squared
between the new is red and yellow one
and by complexity just by rearranging uh
uh that inequality that we saw uh this
difference is that most inner products
uh with x t minus X star
okay
so so we uh so so we get this upper
bound where we have the senior product
between the green and add XT and XT plus
one minus X Star Plus L over 2 times the
uh x t plus 1 minus 60 square
so so now we need to understand uh this
inner product right so so we need to
understand how large can this inner
product be so if we look at the inner
product between the gradient and the
direction between the new internet and X
star what can we say about that
okay
and here um the the way I like to think
about this is actually
uh to think about what x t plus one is
and and once again uh this is where uh
the optimization perspective comes uh in
very handy
so the way we Define XT plus one was to
be at the minimizer of this optimization
problem where we took the
um the a final approximation in this
movement term and we minimized that to
get XD plus one
so so that means that uh uh we can gauge
uh what is happening with HD Plus One by
thinking back to our good old optimality
condition right that we learn in
calculus
so say for the problem is unconstrained
the optimality condition says that if I
take the derivative or the gradient and
set it to zero then I'll get the optimum
uh in the constraint setting there's a
version of this uh that it looks a
little bit different but it's uh is also
very natural so what it says is that if
I'm looking at the minimizer of some uh
some function let's call it Phi
uh then at this minimizer I have this
nice property that the gradient of the
function at the minimizer and times the
direction between the minimizer and any
point in the feasible domain the
scenario product should be almost zero
and and the reason is that uh this uh
this direction y star minus y should not
be at the same direction I should not be
able to improve the objective value by
moving in that direction
because I should why star is the
minimizer and therefore uh
uh I should I so this is not a decent
Direction so that inner product is n100
okay so so if we apply it uh what
happens right so XD plus one is the
minimizer of this function uh that we
put there in our update rule
so if it's a simple quadratic so let's
take its derivative so we get the
gradient at XD plus L times y minus x t
and if we apply the optimality condition
then we get this property that this uh
inner product
um is Atmos zero
so so so this is a little bit fast but
really all we're doing here is very
simple we're just applying the first
order automatic condition absolutely
mechanically and seeing what happens
all right
so so that's what we do and uh and uh we
we get uh this guarantee on this inner
product that just falls out of the
optimality condition
and this is a guarantee that holds for
any point in the feasible domain
um by the optimality condition but of
course for us the
um is most useful when that point
happens to be the uh the minimum X star
that we are trying to uh converge to
right so so we can go ahead and apply it
with uh X Star as at the point of
reference and we could rearrange it and
now we can see that it is going to give
us an upper bound on the inner product
that we obtained before right so when we
looked at
um how the function Gap was evolving
this was uh the inner project that we're
interested in and uh and the really nice
thing about this is that uh we get a
very nice upper bound on it straight by
uh the optimality condition
so so this is a very useful uh way to to
gauge that in that inner product
but of course you know what we have here
and products and it looks a bit
mysterious so what do we do with this
and actually here there's actually a
slight algebraic trick that I like it's
not the only way to think about this but
I really like this uh so whenever I look
at an inner product like this uh it's a
very useful to uh to observe that
um
that I move it bright and I think I have
a typo there should be x-star minus x e
plus one so so the the the the point is
that uh we have this very nice simple
structure here so where we're we're
having some num some Factor times some
other vector and and this uh this terms
are shared
and whenever I see that I I think about
this very useful identity which is that
the way I can write a times B is first
to take the sum and square it so one
half times the sum squared and then
subtract the the terms that I should not
be there right so one half a square and
once have B squared
right uh and uh
so let me fix that type of real quick
foreign
yeah so sorry about that I so so all we
did here was to just move this term uh
to the other side right so so we got x t
minus XD plus one
times x t plus 1 minus X star
so so on the other side we have this uh
very nice uh you know product that has
this really nice structure which is
amenable to this identity right that uh
if we can think of a times b as one half
a plus b squared minus one half a
squared minus one half b squared and if
we applied it to this right we get a
very nice uh equivalent way of writing
this inner product which is uh simply
uh
x t plus one minus X squares star
squared minus x t minus X star squared
so this is very nice because this is a
telescoping sound and we also get uh
this uh this term which is subtracting
the uh the distance squared between the
newly thread and your one
right we had that nice identity
and uh if we put those two things
together uh we get a very nice upper
bound of the financial value Gap right
so just to recap so so we applied
smoothness and convexity to Upper bound
the function value Gap and that gives us
this inner product that we needed to
understand
and and then we use the optimality
condition and see what happens and that
also gave us a very nice upper bound on
the inner product so so we can combine
the two and get a very nice upper bound
on the function value gap which is
simply this telescoping uh terms right
so we have the distance between X star
and the new utero HD plus one minus uh
the distance between AC and X star
squared
and this is very nice because it
telescopes when we sum everything up uh
so see if we sum everything up and
Telescope uh we can upper bound the sum
by uh just the initial distance times
the smallness
and uh as as we saw before the the
function values are uh decreasing or
non-increasing
uh so so we can get a an upper bound of
the of the function value of the final
letterhead
um as the average of all right so 1 over
T times the sum that we had there and
that uh exactly U of the the conversions
that that we were looking for
so that might have been a little bit
fast uh and because by no means the only
way to do this analysis actually there
are many fascinating ways to do the
analysis and uh anupam surveys a great
uh tool for and resource for that as
well but hopefully give you a glimpse of
how my go about leveraging some of the
ideas that are built into ingredients
and things like the lower bounds that
come from convexity and this
optimization perspective
and we with that in mind let me thank
you for your attention and I'm happy to
answer questions
thank you uh questions
for I guess we'll just film a subgrade
don't be the same
many of the ideas yes so another reason
why I like this template is because I
can use a lot of the ideas so the very
first step is not going to be uh the
same
what we can do is actually start off by
uh by the Second Step where we actually
look at the abnormality Foundation
so so so we can bypass this and go
straight to the second idea
and uh use the abnormality condition and
of course that works no matter what
right so we're still going to get this
of course this is uh with the step size
in here that is not one round
uh and we can uh write things nicely and
so forth so so we can do this algebraic
approach that I mentioned uh just just
as well so that all of this is great the
only problem with that now is that
um uh this inner product
uh is not exactly what we want to
understand if the function is non-smode
and the reason is simply because if the
function is not smooth all we have going
for us is complexity
and what we get from convexity well from
complexity what I'm getting is that my
function value Gap right
is upper bounded by the inner product
with the gradient
times x t minus X star
right so if you remember right so we
have so this is XD
and we have this lower bound and the Gap
is uh that is
and the crucial thing is that here is XD
not XD plus one
so so the automatic condition only
allows me to reason about
the inner product with XD plus one the
new uterine right so so this is this is
a key
distinction
so uh so so so actually what I really
want to understand in the non-school
setting is this in a product
but what I can understand the optimal
condition is this other inner product
where XD is replaced by XD plus one
so so we need to do one more step to fix
it
it which is in and the approach is
actually quite simple and that's where
the Lipschitz property the bounded
greeting is going to come in uh and
we're just going to break this up right
so so we're going to break it up
into x t minus X star
plus uh
what is Left Right XD plus one
minus x t
okay
or rather the other way around and so
and um
so so sorry so that's that's how we can
engage things and then we're going to
have this term uh but the the really
cool thing is that we can actually get
rid of the term if the gradients are
bounded because we actually have a game
so it's social it's like here from the
automatic condition we have this game
which is the distance squared between HD
plus one NXT and that will exactly allow
us to offset this loss here
which is the gradient times HD plus one
minus 16. because the gradients are
bounded so if this distance is blowing
up
uh it was only blowing out with the
length of XD plus one
whereas what I did here is actually the
square of the length which is going to
overpower
so that's at a high level how you but if
you do all of this it's going to give
you an analysis thank you
I just want to ask if the AGD plus also
works when uh like the same can can you
prove it's optimal under uh the new
strongly convex like the one you showed
before
in the previous lecture yes great
question so yeah um sorry uh so the yes
uh so so we
uh
that's a great question so when we did
really understand
when we have strong convexity we didn't
have to change the algorithm the
algorithm was still the smooth gradient
the central room we just gathered past
our acceleration
convergence for free without changing
the album
um in the accelerated setting uh we need
to know the strong complexity and we
will and we can use that to change and
change the update to Incorporated and if
we so we can take the let's say AGD plus
and acsa update and uh
um and actually incorporate a strong
complexity and for for those methods we
are going to be able to show
acceleration there's also um more black
box reduction way of doing things uh via
restarts uh so and I'm happy to learn
more about that offline as well
thank you
any more questions
or in that case let's say Colina again
that's it for first